I was just in Belfast last weekend yeah
with your husband
yeah co-creators of Game of Thrones
David Benioff and he and invited me to
come and sort of host a show with the
Game of Thrones cast it's going to be
shown later after this series is over
really fun thing to do it seemed like
they had a great time they all had a
good time but I was thinking to myself
what's it like you have to be away from
your husband for chunks of time while
he's in Belfast and you're here that's
kind of first I just want to I just want
to go back for one second cuz I heard a
kind of a funny story about you going
out to dinner in Belfast in Northern
Ireland
yeah I heard that the editor of Game of
Thrones came over to your table and
started chatting and was pretty cheeky
with you in a way that my husband
thought was peculiar and it turned out
that towards the end of the conversation
she just said and what do you do oh yeah
she's very lovely
I don't bless she's you know she lives
in Northern Ireland she's a sound editor
she's in the dark all the time she had
no idea no idea at all no way the fact
that he wasn't recognized yeah yeah
you're gonna Dirk all the time please
trust me please there are plenty of
people there plenty of people they were
in Northern Ireland who did know I was
and there was a lot of lovemaking going
on between that not me you found it kind
of refreshing and I was gonna ask you if
you thought she was kind of weirdly not
obsequious enough for what you're you
know in terms of what you're used to
no I was I was perfectly happy I come
from a large Irish Catholic family where
people treat me I'll be honest they
treat me like [ __ ] all the time and so
that is actually feels comfortable to me
when someone's just like oh and what do
you do I'm very happy I'm yes or oh you
do that huh you know that makes me feel
like oh I'm with my family this is good
so it was that we had a lovely time and
so I'm just curious is it tough for you
to be away that much it's hard but you
know you stay connected so the way I
stay connected is that my nanny is on I
don't do social media it's not a stance
or anything it's just I'm an imbecile
technologically it's not your thing so
if we need you I just to me it's as if
somebody's like hey how about taking the
math SAT you know to get online to do
the thing like I don't even know I you
don't know how to get online you turn on
the computer there's really nothing to
it you can't convince me that well I
don't know the complicated algorithms
necessary to get online do you know how
to tweet yes I know how to tweet I tweet
all the time yes sorry yeah I'll see I
don't understand how do you tweet all
you have to do is sit with someone for
about 30 seconds they'll set you up with
an account the problem is they're
already bored I don't wanna I mean well
you can't do that not with you okay but
how do you like operate a car you'd be
like I don't want to get behind the
wheel hold around thing
and make a turn PRN be too many letters
it's true really
toothpaste wait a minute on the brush
and then no place is okay it's very
concrete you can count you can see it
right I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I like
your space work it was very good you're
very literal I'm very concrete once you
I don't understand so you you act as
anyway yes did the nanny my nanny so the
other last week for example a plague
went through my house I was barfing and
then my seven-year-old was throwing up
all night I was up all night I'm trying
to open a play and my nanny came and
said look at David in these tweets my
husband wasted in a bunch of pictures
after having gone out with you what am I
in the pictures no I'm not
who was in the picture remember who was
in the pictures who else
Momoa Jason Momoa yes just tell my story
about some in Belfast and we were there
for two days to do this thing and
everywhere I go the people are coming up
to me they're like what do you do I'm
not gonna pretend I'm not gonna pretend
to do a good Irish accent so I'm just
gonna do the Lucky Charms elf because
that's what I'm comfortable with but
everywhere I went they be like Conan
O'Brien oh you just miss Jason Momoa he
went that way
like I'm responsible for Jason Momoa he
got away from you get better go get him
they don't sound like that at all do
they it was I mean you know with it
really sucked now you say you are not a
technical person but you have a lot of
MDS in your family you have a lot of
smart doctors in your family don't you
yeah and I'm not one of them right well
here's what here's why I bring it up
yeah but they're not here yeah yeah
where's those smart guys now yeah
by the way the other thing that I heard
in Belfast was that every time you flog
George I didn't maybe once just one time
every time he flubs like you know as we
do sure I don't know why I'm saying we
you know when something went wrong Peter
Dinklage's will say way to go Harvard
yeah he was he was sitting in the
audience Mahoney had the entire cast of
Game of Thrones in the audience and I'm
on this stage in Belfast and I'm doing
my jokes doing pretty well thank you and
then there was one thing that went a
little wrong and Peter dick was like
nice going Harvard thanks a lot because
you went because he went to Harvard it
seems like you should just be perfect in
every way imminently competent in most
situations I don't know I didn't tell
people how I did there you know that
part never gets brought up it's always
here you went to Harvard yeah well sort
of the Unabomber they're gonna stop
hitting me up for money yes I did
graduate yeah but I was because that's
the most condescending thing yeah he got
his diploma from a colleague from
Harvard know once you get in it doesn't
man trust me trust me please let's not
talk about that
I'm impressed well you should be where I
was what are you talking about before
way to go Harvard yeah yeah no Dinklage
has a way of taking the steam out of you
immediately here's a hilariously funny
guy I love hanging out with him yes I do
very very funny yeah they're a lovely
cast
you